hey guys I'm Erik Bosse now I'm away
from the studio on vacation so I'm
coming to you voice only this time which
means you don't have to look at my dumb
face but you are still stuck with my
voice it'd be great if I could like
spice it up with a charming Australian
accent or something
Haeju Moy nope that's not gonna work
anyway a lot of you have been asking
about rogue one a Star Wars story and I
want to make a quick video to answer one
big question why are there so many shots
in the trailers and promo footage that
didn't make it into the final film and
quick spoiler warning here before I go
any further okay so there are at least
46 deleted shots from the trailers that
did make it in the final film many of
which we dissected like crazy in our
past trailer breakdown videos on this
channel and most of these showed an
extended sequence on scare off' with jen
evading tie-fighter storm troopers and a
TAC tease or a tax if you're a psycho on
the beach while holding the stolen Death
Star plans instead of just transmitting
them through the antenna like she did in
the final version of the movie
and joining casseon and one final
embrace on the beach so many of you are
wondering if there was an alternate
ending to rogue one and if so what that
alternate ending was now before I get to
my theory I should remind you that last
June weeks after that very first teaser
with all those now deleted shots came
out rumors spread about reshoots taking
place some sources said up to 40% of the
film was being reshot including the
film's ending and that the scripts
writer Tony Gilroy was stepping in to
help direct them but Disney and
Lucasfilm downplayed these rumors saying
it was just a few tweaks of people
talking and cockpits and that every
major action film these days has
reshoots and that's true and sometimes
movies will put alternate shots and
trailers that they never use in the
final movie go get him boss
you complete me then more recently after
rogue one came out Gareth Edwards the
director said that a very early draft
that the script did have an alternate
ending in which a few of the main
characters actually survived because
Edwards assumed that Disney wouldn't
want such a dark Star Wars movie but
then apparently Kathleen Kennedy was
cool with everyone dying so that's the
version of the story that was eventually
shot but that doesn't really explain why
they shot all this extra footage and
then decided to remove it clearly there
was another version of this ending that
they did change during reshoots so here
is my best guess of what that was based
on deleted shots plus the most exciting
version this movie I can think of based
on my love of Star Wars and my own
experience as a screenwriter so Jen
cassian and k2s o sneaked into the
Imperial base on Scarab and steal the
Death Star plans and then Jen goes to
the top of the antenna to transmit them
to the rebel ships just like it happens
in the movie but then a TIE fighter
shows up and blows the antenna that
forces Jen casseon and k2s Oh hasn't
been destroyed
to return to the ground level run
through the battle and escape on a ship
with the stolen plans to hand them off
to the rebels in person now another way
this could go since it seemed like Jen
wasn't particularly afraid of that TIE
fighter is that maybe that ship is being
piloted by one of her crew like Bodie or
Kay to us so and that's how they get the
plans up to the rebel ships and that
would make sense
like if the ship was still up maybe they
could have used a TIE fighter to sneak
out either way we know there must have
been more going on on the planet's
surface from these deleted Beach shots
so my guess is there was originally a
longer escape sequence out of the base
and into the battlefield perhaps leading
to a beach showdown against critic who
we saw trudging through a bunch of
floating dead stormtroopers in the
trailer and regardless I think
characters like Bodie bays and cheerin
were always going to die in this battle
and then I think that originally there
was another final sequence that we
didn't see with Jen and maybe a few
others flying up to the rebel flagship
with the stolen plans in person so like
Jen hands them off to a random rebel
soldier and he's like why are you
handing me a floppy disk and Jen's like
it's a stolen Death Star plans and he's
like how do you know that
and she's like because my dad named him
after a nickname he gave me shut up just
hand us off to your boss [ __ ] and
then
Darth Vader's red lightsaber blade
illuminates the hallway then as a
terrified rebel rushes the plans to lay
on the tanta for gin stalls Vader
engaging him in a doomed fight which
ends in Jin's violent self-sacrifice and
both Vader and Gen watch as the tanta
four jumps into hyperspace QED CGI
Carrie Fisher saying hope and credits
now again this is all just my pen
fiction version of rogue ones ending -
some hot Mon Mothma Bail Organa action
that I left out just for your sake but
the reason I think jinn dying at Vader's
hands could be possible is it would make
the finale a lot more personal for jinn
like in this version jinn would actually
see her mission succeed as opposed to
just like flipping a switch and hoping
someone upstairs was listening as the
Death Star wipes her in casseon out also
it would give critic more of a send-off
- but like this wild muddy beat shootout
as his death troopers get taken out one
by one instead of a kind of rush
standoff at gunpoint with jinn now don't
get me wrong I loved the irony of the
death stark Renick built being used to
kill him and I thought Jen and casseon
on the beach was super sweet and kind of
poetic but I could also see a reality
where that was an alternative to a much
bloodier and much more violent earlier
cut of the film and if you think I'm
exaggerating there were rumors about
concept art for rogue one that included
Darth Vader dismembering rebel bodies
chopping them in half and using them as
human shields so you can imagine execs
watching that version and saying like uh
hell no we're not gonna Darth Vader go
Game of Thrones on this movies hero we
still gotta sell toys here and as much
as I would love to see that who knows
there might have been some other awful
or just weird version of the ending that
we're all very lucky not to have seen
and ultimately I was very pleased with
the final cut of rogue one I don't care
how the sausage gets made I just eat it
for $18 an opening night
okay thanks for watching and check out
the other rogue one videos I did on the
CGI for Leia and Tarkin as well as an
explanation of how the movies timeline
tied into a new hope please hit like and
subscribe to new rock stars
you can also contribute to new rock
stars on patreon so a huge thanks to all
of our donors and if you
currently a patron we would love your
support all right thanks for watching
bye